[Musique]
bonjour à vis de vous retrouver pour ce
7 8 sociétés un numéro consacré au salon
de l'agriculture c'est la 57e édition
il se déroule au parc des expositions de
la porte de versailles à paris
de nombreux producteurs et baignoire
enfin le déplacement parts ont déambulé
dans le salon de l'agriculture à leur
rencontre
oui
sur le stand yvelines hauts-de-seine un
producteur événement à la ferme de
grignon vous venez de recevoir récemment
une médaille d'argent pour ce yaourt
entier
oui effectivement et c'est une vraie
récompense pour toute l'équipe
on est très satisfait de ce résultat
comme ça un yaourt nature c'est vrai que
c'est vraiment le process de fabrication
qui implique un qualité une qualité
irréprochable pour le produit au final
est une vraie récompense pour toute
l'équipe de la ferme
on est très satisfaits d'autres
événements à venir également une journée
portes ouvertes tout à fait donc le
dimanche 7 juin
on ouvre nos portes comme tous les jours
d'ailleurs mais cette journée là on met
vraiment le paquet pour vous accueillir
avec beaucoup d'animations avec des
producteurs fermiers pour communiquer
sur le métier aussi l'agriculture
communiquer positivement et donc on vous
attend très nombreux et on espère à
nouveau battre un record qui date
maintenant de bientôt un nom le
territoire des yvelines est composé de
98 mille hectares d'espacés agricoles
avec 950 exploitation le département des
yvelines est le
deuxième territoire agricole d'île de
france il participe pour la troisième
année avec le département des
hauts-de-seine au salon de l'agriculture
le but promouvoir sur un stand en commun
leur territoire il y a autant d'élèves
scolarisés dans les collèges du
département des hauts-de-seine que des
yvelines et nous avons l'ambition de
développer les circuits courts les
circuits courts c'est-à-dire la
production de légumes
la production de viande sur les
territoires où ils sont consommés et
comme dans les hauts-de-seine ils ne
peuvent pas produire plus il n'y a pas
d' espaces agricoles
ils sont tout à fait disposés à
consommer les produits des agriculteurs
yvelinois et j'ajouterai que nous avons
aussi sur nos territoires et en
particulier dans les hauts-de-seine des
entreprises qui ont des restaurants
d'entreprise qui vont se convertir aussi
à ses circuits courts
près de 9 millions de repas sont servis
chaque année dans les collèges du
département des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine
ils ont engagé un plan d'action pour une
alimentation de qualité contribue à un
meilleur équilibre alimentaire mais
aussi privilégier les produits locaux
parmi et les producteurs y situer aux à
lui et le roi fournit des yaourts
y a été créé en 2014 au concours général
agricole
y a eu la médaille d'argent sur un
yaourt à l'abricot destinés à la
restauration collective pour les enfants
du département vous avez également une
autre médaille
oui en effet depuis qu'on a créé notre
note fabrique en 2014 on a eu quatre
médailles au concours avicole en 2000
dont 15 18 19
on a eu des médailles à la fois sur les
yaourts à la grecque donc le produit
qu'on a créé à la base et sur des yachts
classiques qu'on envoie
en collectivité dont beaucoup dans les
cantines scolaires et cette année pour
la 57e édition du salon de l'agriculture
vous proposer une nouveauté pour le
public la mousse au chocolat
alors oui en effet c'était des ondes est
venu avec nos yaourts en pot et d'être
barras gourmandise dans lequel on
propose de goûter la mousse au chocolat
en avant première c'est un produit qui
sera fabriqué en complément des yaourts
avec courant mai ou juin de cette année
et les amours sont à retrouver sur leur
stand également à la ferme des abus et
nous nous trouvons sur le papillon
ile-de-france où l'ambiance d'un
véritable marché a été recréée
nous pouvons constater la diversité des
produits d'ile-de-france du champ à
l'assiette c'est la devise du pavillon
ile-de-france encourager les franciliens
à manger local grâce à la marque produit
en ile de france c'est l'objectif d'île
de france terre de saveurs anciennement
servient tout à fait une des priorité
parmi d'autres mais d'arriver à faire
prendre conscience aux consommateurs que
le territoire le terroir permettent de
fournir une agriculture de avec des
produits de qualité biologique en propre
mais pas que mais c'est un grand retour
rapport au passé de revenir sur des
valeurs qui ont toujours existé sur nos
territoires ile de france terre de
saveurs c'est plus de 1400 produits
référencés vous cherchez aller plus haut
alors contrairement aux idées reçues
c'est yves mans ça peut paraître curieux
qu'on est déjà 1400 produit de référence
et sur notre région pour une région
qualifiée de grande culture très urbaine
et sur laquelle orléans tours il se
passe soit disant pas grand chose et
puis on s'aperçoit qu'il ya beaucoup de
produits de production et de
transformation possible
aujourd'hui on en est à ce niveau là
mais on peut encore évoluer énormément
dans la transformation et
l'ile-de-france est
47 % de terres consacrées à
l'agriculture la région regorge de
producteurs avec ce salon c'est
l'occasion de promouvoir le circuit
court la revalorisation des matières
tout à fait celles auxquelles on est une
occasion on est une localisation une
situation très privilégiée en ile de
france
nous avons 12 millions d'habitants à
moins en moyenne d'une heure de nos
exploitations donc une population qui
est en grande demande de de qualité le
circuit court est une solution est une
réponse à cette à ses demandes
donc on peut faire beaucoup de choses
restent à organiser il ya les circuits
courts
par les commandes de drive aujourd'hui
par internet et paniers fraîcheur dans
les gares qui demandent qu'à être
multipliés et puis aujourd'hui et puis
demain encore les les nouvelles formes
de vent de mise à disposition dans des
casiers aujourd'hui on commence à avoir
par exemple des des parkings de
covoiturage qui sont connectés avec des
lieux on peut retirer des produits
locaux ça ne peut que se développer mais
ça se fait avec
en en parlant et
au fur et à mesure ça peut se faire
également dans les gares et tout ceci
c'est pour répondre davantage à une
attente d'une clientèle qui veut savoir
ce qu'elle a dans son assiette et d'où
ça vient
sans chimie ou sans conservateur on l'a
compris un salon de l'agriculture on
communique sur ce qui est fait sur les
produits continuons notre tour
[Musique]
ça montre quand même une belle vitrine
de notre pays la france j'ai oublié par
les éleveurs qui viennent présenter les
plus beaux animaux qu'ils ont dans leurs
élevages et ensuite le terroir qui a
dans chaque région ça permet de
découvrir voyager au sein du salon quoi
se défendre quand même malgré d'eau
hélas les auteurs maintenant je vois
dans des matches comme ça astor
des moutons en train de
le 30 janvier là on a fait des animaux
les bovins tout ça et puis voilà on fait
le deuxième j'ai vraiment vraiment
vraiment façon c'est le meilleur
pavillon c'est celui-là autre épine wa
présents sur ce salon les deux gourmands
créé en 2012 ils sont implantés à
crêpière non loin de plaisir leurs
gâteaux secs sont parfumés au chocolat
et au beurre mais aussi aux coquelicots
à la moutarde ou encore aux bleus de
chefs tous ou confectionnés avec des
produits d'île de france
les deux gourmand propose également du
miel mais aussi du pain d épices une
nouveauté de ce salon
alors la nouveauté de cette année ce
sont les granola qu'on propose donc ce
sont des flocons d'avoine toaster au
four avec du miel et des fruits secs
dans lesquels on rajoute en fin de
cuisson soit des pépites de chocolat
soit des raisins secs
comment vous est venue cette idée eh
bien comment et nous est venue cette
idée
alors c'est dans notre dans notre élan
normal de développement on regarde un
peu autour de nous ce qui se passe on
regarde les besoins des clients les
désirs des clients les goûts des clients
et donc voilà c'est comme ça qu'on
arrive à créer des nouveaux produits et
les plus gourmands pourront découvrir
ses produits sur le hall 3 c'est
intelligent de leur port pin partager
des idées agricole et tout pour refaire
enfin pour eux pour dire ce que les
paysans ils font enfin pour pas que ça
s'oublie quand ils font un sacré travail
malgré leur paye en 2018 la région ans à
un pacte agricole doté de 150 millions
d'euros soit de 30 millions d'euros par
an d'ici 2022 rencontre avec alexandra
du blanche
le salon de l'agriculture se déroule
dans un contexte d'agri bashing c'est un
mouvement de méfiance envers le monde
agricole est ce que ce salon cette 57e
édition du salon de l'agriculture c'est
un moment pour rassurer et les
consommateurs le salon de l'agriculture
c'est toujours une grande déclaration
d'amour des français à leurs
agriculteurs et on le voit ici sur le
stand ile-de-france qui ne désemplit pas
effectivement il ya près 85 % des
franciliens qui se disent aimer leurs
agriculteurs mais après on voit de plus
en plus de mouvement d' attaque aussi
dans les fermes ou de mes connaissances
aussi du métier d'agriculteur et donc
nous ce qu'on essaye de faire avec
valérie pécresse à la région ile de
france c'est de rapprocher nos
agriculteurs des franciliens en les
faisant davantage se rencontrer comme
ici sur le salon mais également par
exemple en incitant financièrement les
fermes nos agriculteurs à ouvrir les
fermes on va mettre 2 millions d'euros
cette année pour tous les agriculteurs
qui
ouvrent leur ferme pour parler de leur
métier et faire connaître davantage ce
qu'ils font au quotidien et peut-être
enlever un peu d'angoissé des
consommateurs et donc il faut que ces
deux mondes se parle c'est aussi tout le
travail qu'on fait sur les filières là
on est sur le stand yvelinois qui me
tient particulièrement à coeur et là je
vois le lait d'ile-de-france qui est
produit dans les yvelines a autour de
trois ferme et on veut valoriser ces
filières agricoles filière francilienne
le produit local on sait qu'une demande
du consommateur du local et donc c'est
ce qu'on essaye de montrer sur le salon
et tout au long de l'année avec des
marques on a lancé l'agneau
d'ile-de-france les bovins
d'ile-de-france la baguette des
franciliens et on travaille sur tout un
tas de filières également pour
promouvoir nos produits locaux et encore
davantage rapproché l'assiette des
franciliens de des agriculteurs
la ferme de viltain située à jouy en
josas sur le plateau de saclay à côté du
campus hec a elle aussi été récompensé
en 2019
elle la ferme d'ailleurs conquis la
médaille d'argent pour trois de ses
laitages et des yaourts à la framboise à
la vanille est à l'abri peau cette année
vous avez également remporté une
médaille pour votre yaourt à la
framboise
oui on est très content fier aussi parce
qu'on a été a été récompensé par cette
médaille d'argent sur le yaourt à la
framboise
c'est un yaourt qui est qui se compose
de vous avez la confiture et puis lior
par dessus et on mélange l'ensemble
c'est très gourmand voilà et on est très
content parce que c'est un gros travail
on tient toujours compte des
observations qui sont faites d'une année
sur l'autre
on a eu des observations sur le sucre
donc on a diminué un petit peu la
quantité de sucre et voilà et donc bah
finalement c'est le travail d'une année
qui récompense et donc je suis fier de
l'avoir eue mais je suis fier aussi au
nom de tout mon personnel des fromagers
qui travaillent au quotidien à la ferme
et voilà les produits de la ferme de
viltain bénéficient d'autres labels
depuis 2011 vous avez les papilles
saveurs paris-ile-de-france d'autres
appellations également un restaurant de
qualité et producteurs artisans de
qualité
la ferme de huit ans a obtenu le label
bleu blanc coeur notamment pour la
teneur en oméga 3 comment accéder à ces
labels alors nous on était déjà presque
à cette teneur en oméga 3 puisqu'on
avait une nourriture depuis plus de 10
ans déjà qu'ils étaient très diversifiés
donc une nourriture équilibrée pour les
vaches qui était pas seulement un seul
fourrage mais différent fourrage ya de
l'ensilage de maïs il ya du foin derme
de leurs organes et de luzerne du seigle
différentes graines et
et quand on faisait les analyses de
l'est on avait déjà nommé gars 3 qui
était déjà très important mais pas
suffisant ou pas toujours aussi
important que demande le label donc il a
fallu rajouter un kilo de l'un par
action et par jour et grâce à ça et bien
on a toujours à une teneur en oméga 3
très importante
c'est important pour la santé nos
animaux et c'est important aussi pour
notre santé ça me fait très plaisir
d'avoir un lait qui amène une bonne
santé pour tout le monde
vous avez également un autre label pour
vos visites dans votre ferme
oui ça va être bienvenue à la ferme à
nouveau
c'est c'est quelque chose qu'on faisait
déjà mais on n'était pas estampillé
bienvenue à la ferme et tout le monde
qui tout le monde qu'il connaît savent
bien qu'on ait une ferme ouverte on soit
beaucoup d'écoles tous les mercredis on
peut faire des visites avec portes
ouvertes de la ferme avec des personnes
très compétentes qui explique la vie de
la vache sont présents sur la ferme tous
ces produits également sur le stand les
yaourts et le fameux mik
[Musique]
nous l'avons évoqué avec plusieurs
producteurs et binoy le concours général
agricole c'est un temps fort pour les
producteurs et les éleveurs
c'est aussi un gage de qualité pour les
consommateurs
au fil de ses éditions il s'est imposé
comme la référence d'exigence auprès des
professionnels et des acheteurs
le concours général agricole célèbre ses
150 ans chaque année une vache est
l'égérie du salon de l'agriculture pour
la 57e édition idéal massive et superbe
charolaise de six ans a été sélectionné
pour représenter la race et figurer en
haut de la fiche de ce salon 2020
[Musique]
poules cochons ou encore vaches près de
4000 animaux sont présents jusqu'au 1er
mars au salon international de
l'agriculture de quoi a régalé les
enfants
m
dutil a natural et non c'est bien
on a plein d'amis
des animaux dit
je passais devant des
aux hommes qui viennent le baril
toute la campagne pour toi la plus
célèbre des manifestations de l'hexagone
accueille chaque année sur ses neuf
jours de salon plus de six cent trente
mille visiteurs par an
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui t'as remarqué aujourd'hui
c'est la fin de ce sept huit sociétés
vous avez jusqu'au dimanche 1er mars
pour faire un tour sur le salon de
l'agriculture il est ouvert de 9 heures
à 19 heures bonne visite moi je retourne
sur les champs très belle soirée sauf tv
[Musique]